weddings should ruffle feathers I'm not
saying they should be antagonistic
events but a wedding is making clear
that you are leaving your mother and
your father and your husband is leaving
his mother and his father and you were
clinging to one another and you were
forming a new family and you might do
things a little bit differently than
your mother and father might do and
that's a very fine thing I would not a
lot of people want to cave on the
weddings and say I'll just do whatever
my mother-in-law wants or I'm just gonna
they I don't like it but that's what my
in-laws want to do no no he who pays the
piper calls the tune so you might have
to you know you might have to Pony up a
little bit more if if whoever is paying
doesn't like what's going on but no this
is the first act that you two are going
to have as a married couple do it the
way you're going to live your lives